Asam Alum guys how are you guys doing
you might have realized that recently on
my channel that I've been going to
different countries I've been going to
Malaysia to Thailand to this one to that
one Indonesia and I've been trying to
give you some ideas of where to go as a
Muslim family for example or Muslim
couple or Muslim friends group of
friends on holiday or maybe even one
where you uh uh uh want to go and live
as an alternative to the West I'm giving
you some Alternatives some some ideas
today we're in Bosnia we're going to be
looking at what Bosnia have to offer and
I'll tell you something
um if you're in Europe if you live in
Europe the proximity of Bosnia to
European it's in Europe itself is very
close and it's one of the best countries
I've been to in terms of scenery in
terms of culture in terms of vibe in
terms of atmosphere so stay tuned and
see what Bosnia has to offer guys this
is a fantastic uh Hotel you'll find that
it's got a very Islamic environment we
came for breakfast here all the food is
halal you find people coming from all
over the world interesting especially
the gulf
thei and the rooms are very nice as well
so let's go and see the rooms let's
check them out we we're going we're
going to see the presidential suite
we'll follow you guys
okay we're going to we're going to show
open that door okay yeah open up set
up okay okay he's not allowed in here
check it out first and then I'll come
in this is what you do when you see Liv
area what do you do
here you
go so there must be I have to give you a
holistic plan so guys we're here in the
restaurant we're here in the
restaurant so we've got
uh we've got
a we've got this mes mes how do you
pronounce this Mees Mees
meesza pick one mhamad me
y like get on you
coward so okay do me a favor yeah let's
do a
cure come on this this is the time come
on come on for the for the
camera
it guys why why aren't you guys taking
allahar this is one of this is probably
the best view we've had since we've been
here
allahar this is truly truly breathtaking
Subhan
Allah job checking it out let's see
what's going on here oh my gosh brother
what are you doing brother what's this
guy doing here does that look good
actually those look good looks all right
youy get one bit bigger though okay guys
it's a new day it's a new situation we
are on our way to mustar
now 2 2 and a half half hours we got a
long journey me and hijab are going to
be doing some some stuff okay so it's
going to be it's going to be a great
ride inshallah
wow
bro okay and this is this is fresh fish
from this from this River next to us
Subhan
[Laughter]
Allah look at that look at that we've
got like an ottoman style Masid you know
we can see the minates in The View the
mountain there so we're just cooling off
here really to be honest with you not
much to say except that we're cooling
off me you don't have to narrate
everything that you do are you going to
go to the toilet and see I'm in the
toilet here now right now what if I want
to do that
yeah okay guys we're doing
it well this is something in
it it's nice it's not it's not scary are
you scared it's not scary
so that
scary what you say
again Big T you say
[Music]
thato if I don't come back from Bosnia
if I don't come back from Bosnia you
know who killed me so you're afraid of
heights yeah how about m not really do
to him bro do to him he's scared bro
he's scared bro he's scared bro back
back he's back
off guys we you can see brothers are
digging in this is on the way from
mustar to Saro we've stopped over at
this special place where they do fresh
lamb look at this lamb look at this lamb
oh my God look at that look at look at
him going in how is it I haven't tried
it yet I'm going to try it it's good
salty yeah mhm amazing so guys this is
fresh lamb this is actually a special
bosnan Bosnian lambu special thing they
do here let's try it out inshallah you
know when you don't need
sauce is it let me let me
see
wow it's good is it today we are in a
new hotel and this is probably the best
hotel in all of Saro this is if you want
something you know if you want something
a bit more premium for example than the
previous Hotel than the moving pick you
can come for this option this is the
Swiss Swiss Hotel in Saro let's check
out the room
okay absolutely amazing stuff here let's
check it out massive room you can
already see like this is a very very big
room you could probably fit four people
on here we got the brothers here got a
great view panoramic view check it out
look look let's show them let's show
them look look at the view okay we're
going to show you the presidential
suite okay guys presidential suite with
the president himself yeah let me open
the door for you brother you deserve
this you you deserve
wait please don't break please please J
oh okay I know you're not used to
presidential
tweets bro just check out honestly just
check out Hest check out Che guys guys
guys guys sorry video's over oh very my
God this is
literally
oh this is fantastic it's perfect
can't imagine it being anything better I
don't even know what to say I think
we're going to get kicked out of this
hotel after hijab done with it great
stuff this is amazing this is actually
massage okay so okay let me show you how
good I'm at massaging people I'm not
even joking this is actually so good is
it good yeah what my massage yeah really
bro no one's said that to me bro it's
actually good
crazy oh my God guys I don't really know
what to
say uh as you heard you know from the
woman hijab is not used to these things
but okay that's one bedroom wait up one
second let me just see something because
he has to test it okay I have to test
the bed okay he has to test it okay
people are obviously going to be using
the room for different purposes this is
a house it's not sweet this is a oh yes
this
is the right we're here guys me and Musa
and guess who we
found just by chance too we didn't uh
plan this out we're in the same place at
the same time first time together this
is the second time this happened to us
ni the first time yeah Medina so like
Allah puts us together and you're coming
to London as well inshah yeah right
after there's a lot going on so there's
a lot to talk about and uh a lot to see
let's start here with the old city
though let's do it man let's check it
out yeah guys we're here so we're just
you know checking out the old city how
you finding it uh this guy bro this guy
is this guy is just too much bro he's
getting stopped every 5 seconds so than
you that's an
anomaly
69 I'm
shocking so this is what happening man
I'm
B this is thisne are you watching the
sne yeah for me
yeah hello to you
sne amazing yes you'll find out thank
you so much I mean it originates from
Turkey but become more tradition here
now then we have this in Egypt as well
brother oh really yeah what you guys
call it I don't know but when when the
we call it f thought this was Turkish I
don't know but we have I would have
bought you one as well but I didn't know
you were
live already yeah we're live we're live
just doing the intro saying hi to
everybody oh fantastic fantastic oh my
they got the champ coming Walk Place
like champ is here where am I sitting
here H the these two chairs here oh my
God it's
okay why are you in Bosnia we came here
food is great the weather is perfect and
scen is amazing how you good scen has
been great and we got M Nan obviously
the man the myth the legend yeah I was
just showing them the thect we took in
the presidential presidential SE bro I
don't do you think I'm fighting for but
but why the racist why the racist
rhetoric like why the